All right. Welcome back,
welcome back, welcome back.
Now, in many ways, social media
is a brutally honest reflection
of today's culture,
for better or for worse.
Now, here to examine what
social media got right and wrong
this week is Nightly Show
contributor Franchesca Ramsey
with her new segment
Hash it Out Franches...
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)
Thanks, Larry.
So, this past weekend Kanye West
dropped the music video
for his song "Famous."
In it, Kanye West lays in bed
with creepily realistic
wax replicas of celebrities,
including Taylor Swift,
Rihanna, Chris Brown,
Amber Rose, Donald Trump,
Caitlyn Jenner and Bill Cosby.
Oh...
and they're all butt-ass naked.
Gross.
Now, they're
supposed to be asleep,
but to me it just
looks like a crime scene.
But, as they say,
Kanye's gonna Kanye.
But his delusional fans were
quick to defend the video
with tweets like these.
"The 'Famous' video
by Kanye West
is (bleep) art."
"Why are people
shaming this video?
It is art!"
"With your famous video
is one of the most valuable
pieces of art in our time."
The most valuable
piece of art in our time?
I'm guessing you've never
seen an Andy Warhol,
Georgia O'Keeffe
or Jackson Pollock?
If you think this video is art,
I've got an old copy of Hustler
and an episode of Forensic Files
that will
blow your (bleep) mind.
(cheering, applause)
And to add insult to injury,
this garbage video
isn't even original.
"This scene is inspired
by Vincent Desiderio.
Gotta appreciate
the risk and vision."
Risk and vision?
Sure, risky because Kanye's ass
is probably getting sued.
But vision? He just copied
someone else's work.
Hey, HBO, I've got a completely
original idea for you.
It's called Throne of Games.
Trust me, totally mine.
Sure, technically, this video
could be considered art.
But just because it's art
doesn't mean it isn't awful.
Kind of like your nephew's
macaroni self-portrait.
I don't care
if you're in preschool, kid,
working with rigatoni
makes you a douche.
Not to mention,
art can be criticized.
Oh, and criticize it I will.
This video is gross
on so many levels.
It's so misogynistic.
It's not new or creative
to exploit women's bodies.
There are tons of wax tits
in this video
but where
are the wax dicks, Kanye?
(cheering, applause)
Well...
technically,
Trump is a wax dick,
-so you do have one.
-(cheering, applause)
I'll give it to you.
Then you've got Rihanna
next to Chris brown.
You know, that dude
that, uh, abused her?
And let's not forget the video
has multiple naked women in bed
with an alleged serial rapist.
That's right, (bleep),
we haven't forgotten about you.
To top it off,
this masterpiece was made
without any
of these people's consent,
which is so hypocritical.
Kanye, you know how valuable
your public image is.
Hell, you didn't like it
when an Australian artist
did a mural of you
making out with yourself.
And if I'm being totally honest,
Kanye making out with Kanye
is way more plausible
than this freaky slumber party.
Listen, Kanye, I really don't
understand your sick obsession
with Taylor Swift, Amber Rose
or yourself, for that matter,
but this video
really crossed the line.
I have always been a fan
of your music,
but what you do
with your wax figures
in the privacy of your own home
is your business.
Just leave us out of your not so
beautiful dark twisted fantasy.
Franchesca Ramsey, everybody.
We'll be right back.
(whoops)
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)